but first we go to i-teams at david
charns who is in the newsroom with what
one expert
is telling us david yeah christian the
shockwaves of this verdict are being
felt right now all across our country
the world watching as former police
officer derek chovin put his knee on
george floyd's neck
for nine and a half minutes many of the
jurors who just convicted chauvet of
murder and manslaughter had never seen
the entire video
and to put that time that length of time
into perspective
nine minutes ago we hadn't even seen
final jeopardy yet right here on channel
eight
about uh during our last program now you
could say the smoking gun in this whole
thing was that video
i talked to tyler parry who is an
associate professor of
african american studies over at unlv
you know this is what separates so many
past cases
from this one in particular in that
the video itself was so long and you
could see the callous behavior of
shoveling that
it is undeniable that regardless of
whether or not he was using a move that
was endorsed by the minneapolis pd
that that in of itself is a problem that
that even would be
allowable in trying to detain
a suspect of a crime during the trial
chauvin's attorney tried to convince the
jury floyd had died of a heart condition
drug use even carbon monoxide coming out
of the police car
clearly the jury didn't buy that
remember juries have to agree as a group
whether or not to find a person jury